انضموا الينا من رفح مدير مكتب الامم
المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه في غزه جورجيوس
بتروبوليس اهلا بك سيد جورجيوس سيد
جورجيوس بدايه تعليق على ما يطالب به
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني بحمايه مقاره
ويقول بان القصف الاسرائيلي يهدد طواقمه
وايضا المستشفيات التابعه له منها مستشفى
الامل
المحاصر
ن
مرحبا اعتقد ان كل المنشات الطبيه
والانسانيه في غزه يجب ان تحظى بالحمايه
في اثناء الحرب نحن نطالب بذلك منذ اسابيع
بل اشهر ونطالب بحمايه هذه المنشات وكل
الطواقم الطبيه من
واطباء وكل المنشات الطبيه لضمان انهم في
مامن من الخطر طيب وذلك لا يتحقق تقييمكم
للوضع الانساني بعد اشهر من الحرب
والغارات الاسرائيليه والقصف
الاسرائيلي
المستمر بعد هذه الاسابيع من لدينا
2.2 مليون من الناس في غزه يتعرضون لخطر
خطر المجاعه انعدام الماء
والكهرباء ومليون منهم موجودون في رفح في
جنوب في جنوب غزه و 1.7 مليون منهم من
النازحين كل هؤلاء النازحين هربوا رعبا
وخوفا بعد تعرض منازلهم للقصف والان
خيامهم تعرض للامطار نحن لا نمتلك ما يكفي
من الخيم ولا ما يكفي من الماء والدواء
والطعام والماء النقي لكل سكان غزه هؤلاء
ونحن نعيش في بيئه صعبه للغايه ونواجه
صعوبه في السفر الى غزه ونواجه اوقات صعبه
في ايصال الاحتياجات الى الناس في غزه في
الشمال وفي الوسط وفي الجنوب طيب الذي
امنته المساعدات التي دخلت الى القطاع من
حاجه السكان ما نسبه ما تؤمنه من حاجه
السكان كما قلت هناك 2.2 مليون شخص في غزه
ونعتبر كل فرد في غزه في هذه اللحظه وبعد
اشهر القتال يحتاج الى مساعدات نحن نحتاج
للقتال ان يتوقف وهو الامر الوحيد الذي
سيتيح لنا مساعده من يستحق المساعده
وكنتي لما حصل اكثر من 1.2 مليار دولار
امريكي خصصت للمساعدات فقط تم تسديد
60% منها والمشكله انه في الوقت الذي يتم
فيه دفع الاموال ما نزال نحن نواجه صعوبه
في كميه المعدات التي يسمح بدخوله الى غزه
غزه لا تحتاج الى مساعدات انسانيه فحسب بل
الى ايضا دخول المواد التجاريه وبامكان
عند ذاك ان يواجهوا الامور ويجب ان تتدفق
المساعدات والمواد بشكل حر وكامل الى غزه
طيب كيف ترون هذه
المفارقه اموال تدفع لقطاع غزه الا ان
المساعدات التي تدخل لا تزال شحيحه ولا
تغطي حاجات
السكان اعتقد انه دائما ستكون هناك
مفارقات في حالات الحروب في غزه بالتاكيد
نرى ذلك نقول ايضا بان كل ما يصل الى غزه
سنضمن نحن والامم المتحده
وشركائنا لضمان ايصالها فنحن نوفر الرعايه
الطبيه النفسيه الما الغذاء ولكن ما نقدمه
ليس كافيا في النتيجه فهناك حوالي 1.7
مليون شخص في رفح الان ويمكنني ان اقول ان
مدينه كان سكانها 250 الف او 300 ال الان
فيها خمسه اضعاف
السكان ونحن نمكن ان نوفر ثلث الماء فقط
مما كنا
نقدمه من قبل وما انتج من القمامه في شهر
يفوق ما كان ينتج في عامين ولا يمكن
ازالتها البنى التحتيه تم قصفها حتى
اماكننا نحن قد تعرضت للقصف فلا امانه لا
للناس ولا للفرق الطبيه ولا فرق الطوارئ
هم يتعرضون للقصف في بيوتهم وفي
مستشفياتهم وفي كاتبهم وفي خانيونس يستمر
القتال القضيه لا تتعلق فقط
بامتلاكنا للمواد بل ايضا بالقدره على ان
ايصالها لمن يحتاج حتى الطرق احيانا
نجدها مليئه بالمتفجرات التي لم تنفر لم
تنفرج وهناك حاجه لازالتها لكي نستطيع
استخدام الطرق طيب في ظل هذا الوضع الصعب
الوضع الانساني الصعب بعض الدول توقف
تمويلها لمنظمه غوث وتشغيل اللاجئين وهي
من اكبر المنظمات التي تؤمن مساعدات داخل
قطاع غزه اي اعباء يضيف ذلك الى الوضع
المتردي
اساسا الاونر هي منظمه كبيره جدا ولسنوات
طويله هي تعتني بالحاجات الانسانيه للناس
الان
ان الاوان لكل منظمه انسانيه عامله في غزه
بان تلقى تمويلا كاملا لتقوم باداء مهامها
وواجبها فهي تواجه مشكلات نعم لكن يمكن
مجابهه حل هذه المشكلات اذا ما حصلت
المنظمات على الدعم طبعا الامر الاول الذي
نحتاجه جميعا هو ايقاف القتال لوقف الناس
من التعرض للقتل
والترويع
هرب من مكان لمكان
باستمرار شكرا لك جورجيوس بترو بولس مدير
مكتب الامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه في
غزه